hi I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV and
today we're talking with Brian Kaplan an
economist at George Mason University and
the author most recently of selfish
reasons to have more kids Brian thanks
for joining us thanks so much Rodney I
want to start by reading a famous Philip
Larkin verse the conservative English
poet this be the verse they [ __ ] you up
your mum and dad they may not mean to
but they do they fill you with the
faults they had and add some extra just
for you but they were [ __ ] up in their
turn by fools and old-style hats and
coats who half the time we're soppy
Stern and half at one another's throats
man hands on misery to man it deepens
like coastal shelf get out as early as
you can and don't have any kids yourself
where is Philip Larkin wrong Wow
the main read the main way that he's
wrong is thinking that the reason why
being messed up runs and Families is
upbringing right so it is true that
unhappy people tend to tend to have
unhappy kids but adoption twin research
tell us that the reason is reddit II if
it's determined by genetics what's what
it what are the options well I mean
there's a key difference here between
saying that genes explain family
resemblance and Gene's explain
everything right right so family
resemblance is far from perfect so
there's plenty of wiggle room for a
video for all kinds of things to be
going on really what adoption twin
research tell us is that whatever reason
people differ from what you'd expect
from their genes it's not because the
way they're raised but something else
could be ah I mean but it is
environmental then on some levels so
what what are the types of if it's not
the way you're raised what are the
interventions that change people from a
genetic predisposition so that's a great
question and the answer is there's very
little known about this whenever someone
puts forward a specific story about what
else is going on besides genes usually
turns out that the effect is small or
just non-existent so the really the way
that I thought I would describe things
is according the best science we have
people or product of genes plus question
mark right and the question mark is big
it's a lot of stuff and the way we know
this is identical twins race together
are still far from identical in any
interesting way what what is the most
promise
inquiry into those those question marks
what what seems to be the most thing if
it's not parental intention what's
what's the biggest x-factor that we
might be able to start identifying well
one that is probably never going to get
its proper credit but I think deserves a
lot is free will you our ability change
others is overestimated our ability to
change ourselves is underestimated when
I take a look at my my identical twins
you know they genetically the same race
together yet they're different and a lot
of times I think one is just making a
better choice than the other one or at
least a different choice again like so
the scientific study of free will is
greatly underdeveloped but I don't think
that Sheba should be dismissed I think
that's it's for you I think there's a
lot more going on there than what most
people are willing to admit what's
what's the upside of having kids there
there I would say there are so many
different reasons there are as many
different reasons as there are people
the reason why I call my book selfish
reasons to have more kids rather than to
have kids is I just want to say look
there's a lot of evidence out there that
parents have much less effect on their
kids than they think which means that a
lot of parental sacrifice and suffering
is unnecessary you can raise the kids
that you are going to have in a much
less painful way which I'm painful or
both yeah yeah both although here I'm
focusing more on painful for the parent
right which means that the kids who want
or cheaper than you think so here I'm
thinking just like a typical economist
saying look if it turns out that
something is 25% cheaper than you
thought
you might want to put more on your cards
and it turns out that you can raise kids
without giving up your favorite hobbies
you might want to have a kid that you
weren't gonna have you might want to
have another kid and I mean part of this
is I think it in your book or in
discussions about what you point out how
if you are you know if you're miserable
and the kid is miserable dragging them
to Taekwondo or soccer or piano lessons
don't do it that's right so I mean
really the no-brainer is if you don't
like something your kid doesn't like it
and there's no longer a benefit don't do
it well now of course this is you know
you've engaged in debates with a Michu
of the tiger of tiger mom then where she
seems to be taking the exact opposite
position which is that if it if it
bothers the kid do it but certainly you
know the way you get your kid to
Carnegie Hall by the time there
12 is by kicking their ass and also
meaning that the parent also has to
regiment her life where is true or wrong
well I mean I mean the first place where
she's wrong is in attributing her
daughter's success to parenting there's
there's a basic fact here Amy Chua is a
yale law professor and a best-selling
author her husband is also a yale law
professor and a best-selling author the
first chance I get I said is there some
possibility there's some connection
between the incredible success of even
your husband and the fact that your
daughters are successful and she just
said well that isn't what the book was
about but I say it should but that's
what the book should have been about
does she really think that she could
just take a random adoptee and turn and
turn him or her into a musical prodigy
now I wouldn't know by the same token I
mean musical prodigies don't just
present themselves I mean she her
daughter might have perfect pitch or
whatever but unless she's in lessons
unless she's in a slipstream to show up
at Carnegie Hall or wherever it's not
going to happen
right well I mean here's what I say is
there is an important exception for
things where you have to start doing
them really young in order to be in
order to become successful so to
becoming at Yale now an Olympian an
Olympic athlete or musical prodigy if
your parents aren't willing to get up at
4:00 in the morning then you can't do it
of course most people even if their
parents did get up at 4:00 in the
morning they still wouldn't be able to
do it you know one of the things if
you're a libertarian and the parent as I
am as you are one of the things you get
thrown in your faces I was a libertarian
until I had kids or
you know what what's you know
libertarians can't be parents because
there are they're hate kids or they
refuse to discipline them or structure
their lives what's the connection
between your your insights from the book
and libertarian thought right so mean
one thing that libertarians have known
for a long time is there's a very big
difference between intentions and
results
just because someone intends to raise
their kid in a certain way doesn't mean
the child really will
and what adoption twin research bear out
is in fact just because people are
struggling really hard to mold their
children into a certain shape doesn't
mean that means that it's going to work
and in general in general it works much
less than people expect really the
libertarian perspective that every child
is an independent individual and just
going to make his own choices is borne
out by the science to an amazing extent
politics is also also is a very strong
genetic component so if you really want
to do something for the future Liberty I
do I would say have more kids just by
having them you can increase
the number of libertarians even if you
give them up for adoption even if you're
donating sperm the I there are so there
are significant odds that child will
grow up to be a libertarian someone will
care about liberty you know general rule
yeah like any group that does not value
having kids dies out right so and
libertarians should take this to heart
you have three children yourself having
more are you gonna have well it's not
entirely up to me and my wife and I are
both about 40 I'd like to have more but
I don't know if it's in the cards I I
can hope all right well thank you very
much Brian Kaplan author of selfish
reasons to have more kids GMU economist
thank you very much thank you very much
it's been a Greek letter for reason TV
I'm Nikolas
you